good morning members
good morning members of the public
you're all very welcome here this
morning
and i'm very pleased to say that we're
all here in person and
able to see each other which i think is
a step in the right direction and
hopefully this is
the way forward and we'll get back to
more normality as soon as possible
but please bear with us with the social
distance and rules
which we have to govern by um
you're all welcome here this morning to
begin council's planning committee
meeting
first maori remind you of some of the
domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distance
from all other persons in the chamber
and in the social
areas please ensure that you wear a mask
unless you are speaking or if you are
unable to do so
and that you use the hand sanitizer and
weight provided
and they're all dotted around the
chamber
please maintain social distances at all
times
during the meeting and during any breaks
please ensure that the microphones
are muted when you are not speaking that
you do not interrupt the other speakers
members are reminded that they should
not have alternative
communication lines open i.e
other time team chats
and that if you are con contacted
by a third party during an application
you should bring this to the legal
advisor's attention
if you're attending the meeting to speak
and persistently interrupt the meeting
you may be asked to leave
additionally you will be invited to
speak and ask questions by the chairman
of the meeting
and we will be using the e photon system
for this meeting on
modern.gov dot
robert can you give us the fire safety
arrangements please
thank you chair so the fire safety
arrangements are
if you hear the alarm leave the building
immediately via the fire exit and make
your way
to the assembly point in ipswich foot
town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exits at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium ground floor
area or walkways if you are in the
atrium
at the time of the alarm follow the
signs to the nearest fire exit
use the stairs not the lifts and do not
re-enter the building
until you are told it is safe to do so
thank you chair
thank you very much i'd like to remind
everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewings
the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or
exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to being recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council
and to the possible use of those sound
recordings for webcasting
and all training purposes the council
members of the public and press may
record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd like to introduce the officers
present today
ian d press the legal advisor mark
russell
area planner manager robert carmichael
governor officer jasmine weimar case
officer
for the boxford case and samantha
summers
the case officer for the ashington case
all right i will know and we've got ward
member
um bren haram present also
can i now move to the agenda apologies
for absence
and any substitutions do we have any
robert
thank you chair we have apologies this
morning from councillor lee jameson
thank you and to
receive any decorations of interest by
members are there any
uh councillor
i'll parker a local non-procurement
interest in items
uh number six b and c by virtual mac
member uh for passington parish but i
will be remaining
on the committee
okay i'm very sorry for this the
computer goes
off and i have to keep redoing it
uh item number three to confirm the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of may
2021 um you've all been saying copies of
these
can i ask if there's any um
corrections or anything anybody wish to
comment on them
page one page two
page three
page four all right there's been no
hands done up
can i have a proposition secondary
proposed by councillor plum and seconded
by councillor osborne
all those in favor please share thank
you
sorry oh sorry well
electronic voting today i'm afraid thank
you
just testing to serve you on the board
right
will you take us through to the
electronic station please
yes of course yeah so if members could
please go to their modern.gov app
and go to the plus sign in the top right
hand corner that will bring down the
subsection
slash attendance tab and if you click on
voting the vote will be shown in
progress in a light blue color
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that's carried unanimously
thank you i've lost it again
all right we'll move on
um item four
is to receive notification petitions
uh rob
thank you chair we have one petition to
report this morning
um associated with application dc20330
which was reported to the committee the
previous time
that the application was before members
and in light of the
of the judicial review i will report it
to members again for completeness
the petition has been signed by 96 valid
signatories supporting the following
statement
we the undersigned petition the planning
committee at baber district council to
reject the catesby estates application
dc
zero zero 20 three zero to build new
homes on land to the east
of sandhill boxford thank you chair
we'll note that item values
is site inspection inspections are there
any from offices
no any from members councillor busby
yes chair just to put on early warning
that
we've got an application coming forward
for hintersham hall
and because of its historic and heritage
uh significance the it's likely to be
a tricky one and
at the moment it's not destined to come
to committee but i would like it to do
and also i think it would be worthwhile
as having a site visit to
appreciate the potential harm that could
be caused
caught out on one like this urban
council i'm sorry um
robert can you uh give councillor busby
the same answers you gave me about ones
i wanted to call them great hormones
thank you chair so if any applications
are um
you not to be heard by the committee
people wish to have side visits they
would still have to go through the
delegation panel first
so um thank you for bringing that to our
attention council but just so we're
clear that we'll have to go to
delegation panel first before we can
go to and request any site visit
okay do i need to do anything else or is
that sufficient for you to discuss it
uh you'll have to complete the form and
send it to mr is bill as the chief
planning officer
and then he'll bring it to our attention
thank you
right we'll move on uh item six
um is the schedule canon applications
six a is um planning application at
boxford the case
officer the jasmine one i believe
the chief planning officer is also going
to comment on this so
we'll open this up and mr russell would
you like to
make your statement thank you yes chair
can i just check can everybody hear me
okay
okay if you'll bear with me for two or
three minutes um
so members will be conscious that this
application has been reported back
following the
judicial review uh sorry about handover
i'm pleased to do the hello thank you
um so as i just begun um members will be
aware this is quite a contentious
application and has come back
after the judicial review um and amongst
the items raised then although not
covered by the findings because
we can see it on point one were those
regarding the highway issues
um the officer's report still shows that
county highways do not object
and they feel that the impacts can be
mitigated appropriately
but members also be reminded of
disagreements before on highway matters
in boxford
most famously the daking avenue case
where members refuse the application
despite the high authority not objecting
and the inspector
agreed with the refusal basically so
we're aware that this is a
very contentious issue in oxford and we
are
desirous that there should be public
confidence in the planning process
and that everything is considered
properly and this spills onto
possible effects on the conservation
areas where we look at street furniture
which
might be used for calming etcetera so
it may be appropriate share my suggests
that
we have your permission members to seek
a second independent
highway opinion on the impacts of the
development and the mitigation
that would include the effects on the
conservation area because of street
furniture etc
and then report back to members
with the with the findings and i also
understand that
there's been mention of the site visit
as well i don't know if you want to
discuss that but certainly on the first
point
about um deferral for a second i was
opinion i think that would be the
most prudent course of action at the
moment um
thank you for that well i certainly
think that
um a site inspection um
would be in order here um could that be
added in
um i think i'm quite happy to propose it
and i think the
vice chairman was happy to second this
may i knew once that chair we're still
in a position where
we cannot definitely guarantee a site
visit and
robert carmichael can probably fill in
more detail so if we could
phrase it in such a way as we do a risk
assessment and try and achieve a site
visit
if possible and if not we will come back
we'll do a video sequence et cetera as
much as we can to make it like a real
site visit
if we're allowed to do one and we can
risk assess it and do one we'll do one
that would be at the earliest after the
21st of june
uh that's my understanding that we might
be able to this is outside our control
but i know suffolk county council
planning committees
uh have managed to work one in um
so hopefully um we will be able to get
there
but i think we have to take on board
that um there's a possibility
but we would like the site inspection if
at all possible would be added in
i have some words to check if i may
share them yes just just send that
can i just check with councillor plum
he's happy with that as well thank you
so if you can add that in your word and
that would be fun
so the the two the two limbs of this are
that
um members instruct the chief planning
officer to
a seek a second independent highways
opinion
upon the impacts of the development and
the mitigation b
establish in detail the boundary of the
highway because that is one of the bones
of contention
and the relevant ownerships which may be
affected by the highway mitigation works
and that'll be in consultation with the
highway authority and c
evaluate and report back to committee on
the potential heritage or
other impacts of any such highways
mitigation works
that's the first one in terms of the
site visit the proposed wording is that
you should instruct the chief planning
officer and corporate manager
of governance to review the risk
assessment and mitigation measures
appropriate to facilitate
a committee site visit having regard to
the principles for such site visits
in the planning charter and to seek
agreement of the council's tactical and
senior management team to that end
and subject to that agreement make
arrangements for the site visit or
report back to members if we cannot do
the site visit
members you've all heard
that um been put forward uh councillor
barrack you wanted to speak
yes thank you
i've done this that yes that's right um
can i just ask what
the weight of the independent report
will be
because you've already got the suffolk
highways report so how does
how do the two that's a good question
um we'd have to pay due regard to it
basically um
the point is that this is a contentious
application at some point
be it through a public inquiry or
further judicial review we'd probably
have to seek another
independent assessment anyway so we may
as well do it outside of that
and just do it now before any decision
is made
thank you we don't want to get into
debate i will come to um councillor
parker
but i will get the lawyer to comment at
the end of all this for
us okay thanks counselor
uh yeah i just um welcome
um you know this potential intervention
um general i think it's eminently
sensible actually so
i'm delighted to hear it but have we got
any um notion of
uh timing how long it might be before we
um
we get this back again no no counselor
we don't that's right
okay sorry
right you've all heard it um did um
did you want to make any comment at all
thank you very much right members you
you've
heard that it's um i'll propose that we
go for that determined
with a b c and adden on the site
inspection
with the restrictions in place
and councillor plum has seconded that
so i'll now go to electronic vote
robert can you take us through it please
chair just to double check then so what
i will put in the recommendation for
members to vote on is
politics chair so what i will put in the
recommendation
for members to vote on is the
application dc20330 be deferred
for for a site visit and for the reasons
as read out
by the area planning manager is that
acceptable chair
okay right
and just to conclude that the full
wording will be recorded in the minutes
as well
um and put on the website so
um the vote
we'll be in progress soon apologies
so the vote is now in progress so if
members could please go to
the modern.glove app and go to the plus
sign in the top right hand corner for
today's agenda
and go on the attendance and voting
subsection
and then click on the vote that is in
progress in the light blue color
you're just waiting on one vote chair
if not councillor barrett would you like
to take your vote verbally yeah i'll
agree
so there's four thank you so chair all
votes have now been received
um and that is unanimously for the
proposal
thank you very much uh just at this
point like to
say to the members of the public and
those people have turned up for this
plan and application at boxford
uh apologize for that but we don't know
the result until we have a photo as to
what would happen
as you can see this morning but thank
you for your time
and you will be informed in due course
when it will eventually come back to
this planning committee
so thank you very much all for attending
chair before we move on to the next item
could i just ask for a very short break
to um
uh move around places as we can't fit
everyone as capacity we have some people
outside
yes members will take a
ten minute break so that we can clear
the chamber and start again
thank you
welcome back members we're now back in
our full
council meeting can you hear me thank
you
um right we are then moved to item
6b which is uh land at washington
um and i'll ask case officer samantha
summers to take us through this
thank you
good morning members this application
seeks outline planning permission for
the erection of
18 dwellings at land to the east of
assington barns
the application comes to committee
because it is a major proposal
the matters that members are deciding
today are the principle of development
on the site
the number of dwellings and the access
point pre-application
discussions were entered into for nine
dwellings on the site and a negative
response was given
assington barnes is a complex of small
businesses on the main street running
through the village
the application site is marked
in the pink hatching
and is currently used as a caravan site
the red line shows the application site
which is
uh in the same ownership as the barn
complex
and land to the east of the application
site
the land was also owned
sorry the land between the complex
and the application site was also owned
by the applicant
that has been sold off for development
of 15 dwellings
the application site would be accessed
through a housing development from the
public highway
and you can see that marked in orange
the access point has planning permission
for the 15 dwellings the site is wholly
within a special landscape area
and the site is outside of the built-up
area boundary of assington which is
shown with the brown
line around the village there is a
listed building to the north which is
shown
in orange but this is not considered to
be constraint of the development
because of its distance from the
application site
an application was approved in 2018 for
eight dwellings
to the west of the application site this
included
the new access point for both the
housing development and also for the
yesington barnes complex
the existing access would be stopped up
later in 2018 a further seven dwellings
were granted planning permission
this has resulted in the caravan park
being cut off
from the access once the houses are
being built
the current access runs to the north of
the site
to the caravan park
the new access point is shown going
through the eight dwelling
development to the bottom of the site
there
affordable housing contribution was not
sought on either of these developments
because their individual numbers did not
reach the threshold requirement for
affordable housing
in 2019 the caravan site came in with an
application for outline planning
permission for the erection of 19
dwellings
on the 26th of february last year the
planning committee refused that
application
following a site inspection the reasons
for refusal
included landscape harm and a lack of
information on local housing need
the new settlement boundary in the
emerging joint local plan is shown with
the purple line
the site is outside of the new
settlement boundary the joint local plan
is a regulation 22 stage
and is currently under examination
therefore limited weight is given to
this document
this shows the settlement boundary for
assington in the neighborhood plan
the blue star marks the application site
there are two housing sites close to the
site one is for 15 dwellings
that you've already seen they are
currently under
construction at the moment the other
site is to the north of washington
barnes
and permission has been granted for up
to eight dwellings
assets has not allocated any further
sites to those already granted
permission
the essington neighborhood plan has been
through examination
and therefore the policies are given
significant weight at this stage
the neighborhood plan is a material
change to when the last application was
heard at committee
the proposal before members today is for
the erection of 18 dwellings on the
caravan park
the indicative layout shows 10 detached
three-bedroom bungalows
one detached four-bedroom bungalow and a
terrace of
seven one-bedroom armed house type units
there is no affordable housing proposed
however
the seven arm houses are proposed for
over 60s
a robust local housing needs assessment
did not accompany
the application and therefore it is
unclear whether ascertain needs the type
of housing proposed
this is a plan of what the arms houses
may look like
this google image shows the site in
context we have assington barnes
with the access to the caravan park to
the uh north
west of the site uh three new
dwellings have been constructed in the
south western corner
did you want me to go back yeah just go
back to that
so at the top um the essington barn
section can you can you see that car
park
sorry we're working in tandem here
someone's being my hands
yeah these are a few little hiccups that
we're experiencing
but uh hopefully we'll be able to find
our way through it
okay so ashington barns are the
buildings on on that western boundary
the access to the caravan park is just
to the north of that and
runs along along the top of the site
to the caravan park yeah
along that trackway yeah
[Laughter]
and the caravan park is on that right
hand side of the picture
uh the 15 dwellings there currently um
under construction are where that red
blob is and goes down right to the
bottom
with the new access point just above
those three new houses
along the road frontage just there
yeah if you go up a bit yeah if you
follow that little track way actually
back into the car park if you
sorry if you go down yeah and then left
yeah yes correct so that would be the
new access point
into the caravan park uh that's also the
act the new access
onto the public highway the existing
access would be stopped
up that you can just see going into the
car parking area
the application site has planning
permission for no more than 22
touring or seasonal caravans and tents
19 static caravans and 22 storage
caravans
the static caravans and caravan pitches
have an occupancy restriction that they
shall not be
in a person's soul or main residence
and their occupation is limited to 11
months of the year
moving on to some photographs of the
site looking north within the site
and just in that bottom right hand
corner you can see the blue arrow which
is showing the direction that the
photographs were taken
again looking north within the caravan
site
from the southern edge where the four
bedroom bungalow would be positioned
and that's looking north
this would be the site of the arms
houses running along that boundary
this is showing one of the concrete pads
for one of the static caravans that has
already been put in place
and there's another one there
this is looking towards the access point
so behind that tree line is where the
new houses are currently under
construction
and where the access point would break
through that hitch ray
this is looking west to the development
site so behind
those trees again is where the houses
are currently under construction
this is the access uh into the adjacent
field
that is not a part of the application
site
and is to the east of uh the application
site
but it is in the ownership of the
landowner
and this is uh looking out at the top of
the site at the north uh looking across
the paddocks
into the open countryside
development of essington barnes has
arrived as piecemeal
development which can be seen again
today with two more applications
the site is outside of the built-up area
boundary and also outside of the new
settlement boundary proposed in the
joint local plan
and is shown within the essington
neighborhood plan
the development is considered to be
harmful to the special landscape
area no affordable housing contribution
has been proposed
no evidence has been provided that
flooding can be controlled on the site
a full local housing needs assessment
has not been produced it is unlikely
that seven small
one-bedroom bungalows are something that
assington needs
a better mix of housing for young
families would be more appropriate
the proposed development is not
considered to be sustainable for the
reasons mentioned
and are contrary to policies cs11 cs15
cs19 of the course strategy and policies
contained within the essential draft
neighborhood plan
this application is recommended for
refusal as set out on page 88 of your
agendas
thank you thank you very much for that
report
um members is there any questions that
you wish and clarification
counselor hinton
thank you mr chairman um just a quick
question for the officer on the
conditions surrounding the current use
of the caravan site
i noticed in the pictures that we're
talking about what might be called
out of season but the place seems to be
fairly full of caravans are these
permanent occupancy residential or
touring caravans what's the conditions
for yeah
so um it does have permission uh for 22
static caravans on the site uh some of
the concrete pads you saw there have
already been
installed um and all 22 could have those
however that the restriction
is not for permanent residential use um
it is
for um use for 11 months of the year
and not to be for the sole occupancy
or as the sole main residence of the
occupants
so essentially they are holiday caravans
thank you any other questions members
no thank you very much then
we'll move on um we'll now go to the
public speakers
we have parish council andrew hill
present
uh you say i have three minutes in which
to address the committee and i'll see if
there's any questions for you afterwards
you can take your mask off to speak
okay when you're ready
[Music]
good morning i'm here to speak on behalf
of aston parish council
and local residents the parish council
feels that the officer's report is fair
and balanced and therefore i'm here to
highlight key points and give further
context
the parish council has supported around
50 percent of recent planning
applications and we are supportive
of sustainable development in the parish
however the council strongly objects to
this
application primarily on three grounds
firstly there is substantial harm to the
landscape and village character
the location of the application is an
open countryside and
is publicly visible from a number of
footpaths as well as the playing field
and fighting gardens
there's a special landscape area and the
open countryside forms a key part
of the character of the parish the
application site stretches well beyond
the victory estate towards asked and
brooke
and well beyond the small closes which
have been given permission in recent
years
the applicant relies heavily on the fact
that there are static hair vans on the
site
currently these are no more than 2.5
meters in height as you can see in those
photos
and can therefore be screened very
effectively with low hedging
eighteen houses of five and six meters
in height clearly cannot be screened
particularly given the valley side
location substantial harm would result
as the officer points out in combination
with other approved permissions in the
area
it will constitute a housing estate of
over 40 homes
jutting out into the countryside near to
a village which has always
always had a linear assessment pattern
it would be completely out of character
my second point is about flood risk and
aston has a history of flooding which
has been made worse in recent years
by planning approvals for new housing
the main street floods regularly with
many housings
having to erect sandbags for much of the
winter in order to prevent water
entering the buildings
this includes a listed building in the
center of the village which is also on
the map
i was pleased to see that suffolk county
council requested a flood
assessment from the applicant as members
will be aware almost for forthcoming
and foul water discharge is also a
problem issue in the village with ascent
and brook being used to discharge
treated foul water from new developments
something which has a terrible impact on
local
biodiversity and which is now forbidden
in the neighborhood plan
finally i want to talk about the housing
lead point it's brilliant to see that
yesterday neighborhood plan has been
given weight in this planning decision
it took hundreds of hours of volunteer
time to complete over a period of two
and a half years there are five
consultation events
multiple surveys and a huge effort put
in by everyone in the village
this is the first major application to
be determined in light of that
and neighborhood plan the napa plan
um makes clear there's no need for
additional housing in the village
and babies set a requirement for
ashington 38 houses
and the neighborhood plan has provided
for 67. and the officer made
an error in one point of fact which is
that we have allocated
an additional site which has not got
planning permission in the neighborhood
plan
the local community has therefore been
successful in identifying sustainable
locations for development and i
therefore request
that the committee reject this
unsustainable application
thank you very much well-timed and a bit
of help
no i'll see if there's any questions for
you sir any questions to the parish
council
from uh councillor ayers
tom yes thank you very much for your
presentation
i just wondered about the armed houses
would there not be a possibility for
people who were
wanting to downsize to actually go into
them and would there be
a um would there be a restriction on on
the age group
if that would help just a thought i'd
love to have
elms houses in ashington these are not
alms houses
there's that i i approach the arms house
association
for the definition of the term uh which
is that it's a property built
to be gifted to a charity to be run for
the benefit of the local poor
this these are not those the terms has
just been used
in order to make the in my opinion
application look more favorable to the
committee
thank you any other questions
no thank you very much sir and we'll
move on
um i now have uh an objector helen
wallace
do you have three minutes in which to
address the committee
so i just press oh it's on good morning
everyone thank you
i'm speaking today as chair of the
ashington neighbourhood planning group
and a resident of barracks road
we've worked and consulted with the
residents of ashington since 2018
to develop and reflect their views in
the neighborhood plan
whilst conforming with the joint local
plan requirements
we oppose this development of 18 houses
as we did the previous
application for 19 houses on this same
site
for the following reasons assinton as a
hinterland village has already far
exceeded its minimum requirements of 38
new homes
by making provision for 67 new homes
in the neighborhood plan and so there is
no demonstrable need for these extra
houses in the village
renaming the smaller houses as alm house
style
is at best misleading this development
is in an area of local landscape
sensitivity
and therefore any development should be
in harmony with the special character of
the area
the addition of this development to mr
thane's current development
on adjoining sites would create an area
of high density housing
with a cerebral uh central urban feel
and so
change the character and community of
our linear rural village
this development will clearly have a
negative impact on existing wildlife
habitat in the village
traffic congestion would increase on an
increasingly busy street
both in the construction period and by
the new residents
living there privacy of residents in
barracks road will be affected
not even a well-established hedge can
prevent houses of five to six meters
and the associated light pollution from
being seen by the residents
from their houses and gardens spoiling
what was once a rural
outlook onto the orchard the current
developments is clearly
visible by my neighbor's properties
assinton has a network of good public
footpaths
however a footpath leading from the back
of barracks road to the village shop
which used to be used by many was lost
when mr thane boredom developed this
land
residents now have to walk down the
increasingly busy
barracks road with no footpath to access
the village shop and the center
so ashington's vision for 2036
is to remain a rural attractive village
having protected its countryside setting
by ensuring that new developments
is in proportion to and respectful of
the character of the village
whilst at the same time maintaining a
thriving vibrant and open community
if this development were to go ahead
this vision would be severely
compromised
thank you thank you very much
members have you got any questions that
you wish to ask the objective
counselor hinton thank you mr chairman
um i've been looking at the
infrastructure delivery plan
and various aspects of that where is
your
primary school that your children go to
at the moment and what are the
facilities are there in the village
besides the shop for children
for
[Music]
just very anybody
um sergeant interrupt welcome back to
you
uh rob what is it i'm sorry
it's just because um mrs wallace wasn't
didn't have a microphone on
so it couldn't be heard oh sorry
i'd better speak this way
right i've been looking at the
infrastructure delivery plan and looking
at primary schools in particular
and i the question really is is there a
primary school in ashington
and what other where do they go to a
school and what other facilities are
there in the village
okay assinton has no school and so they
go
the primary children tend to go to
boxford school or some of the
private schools around and then for
senior schools they
they go to thomas gainesboro in sudbury
or colchester grammar
there's there's various options for
senior but we don't we don't have
a school in the village
thank you thomas gainesville school is
in great corner
that's quite all right we don't have a
lot of allocation no great corner but
we do have thomas games for school there
it is a very good one thank you
uh right any other um
comments or questions members
thank you very much thank you um i just
need to ask
um is there a supporter present that
wishes to speak
no is the applicant present that wishes
to speak
no thank you so i will now move
into debate kenzler parker
has decided to stand the committee
because he is also the ward member
by staying on the plan committee he can
uh take part in the debate
i will now ask him to open the debate
councillor parker
excellent thank you very much chair and
and to be honest i don't i don't really
plan to
um uh to say too much at this stage
i'll be interested to hear what my
colleagues have to say um during debate
the officer's recommendation is is
folsom and of course we've heard from
from members of the parish council as
well
um one thing that i would immediately
ask just for some clarification around
from the planning officer if i may is
that um
you mentioned that there is a material
change this time round from the
application that was heard in february
of last year by virtue of
the status of assington's neighborhood
plan and where
where we're at with with that um and my
understanding is is that we
uh or examination has taken place um
with the neighbourhood plan but it's not
yet at referendum but
um i i think i'm right in saying that
that fundamentally
shifts the weight that we attribute to
that plan could you give me some
some clarification on that yeah so
in february 2020
[Music]
there was a draft neighborhood plan
we're still in a draft
however it has gone through examination
uh
examiners comments have been taken on
board and we are waiting for a
referendum date
so previously we didn't give any weight
to the neighborhood plan because of its
very early stages
now we give it significant weight
because we're waiting to go to
referendum on it
um so that is the material change it is
the most
up-to-date piece of policy that we have
really
in terms of our local planning policies
um
and we will be steered by that it has
far more weight than the
emerging joint local plan currently has
thank you any other comments
remembers no
uh counselor busby yeah we said that
there wasn't uh
haven't conducted a housing survey for
this particular application
i presume there was one done for the
neighborhood plan was that
uh yes i think that's correct and um i
think
the parish council might be able to
answer that question really mr mr hill
do you know
did you conduct a name um a housing
survey
we didn't conduct a formal housing needs
survey for hashington
and we made inquiries through the
questionnaire process
right i think the answer is no
counselor busby uh sorry counselor plan
can we just clarify that when when you
say you haven't done a housing survey
you have put it into your questionnaire
at the beginning of your
neighborhood planning process housing
need survey if i'm correct it's a formal
document conducted by an external party
yeah we were advised by baber that we
didn't need to do that
and therefore we didn't but you did
include something like that in your
question and it did survey every house
in the in the
in the parish yes yes so the parish does
have a theory
exactly thank you thank you thank you
any other um questions
or comments uh counselor airs
thank you chair um i was just worried
about the flooding problem could we have
a little more information about
the worries about the flooding please
it was raised by the floods team at
suffolk county council but i haven't
received
any information from the planning agent
to address any of those concerns during
the application process
flooding is something that needs to be
sorted out at outline stage and not left
to reserve matters
thank you any other member wish to
comment
no um
counselor barrett
sorry there seems to be quite a lot
against this application really um
with um the uh
um no no evidence of justifiable need
yeah yeah no evidence of justifying will
need
it seems to be a bit of a problem in a
stumbling block for this application
i can sort of understand why it's
recommended refusal um
considering how many houses have been
built in the village i i can appreciate
that
there you know the even you although you
haven't got evidence
hard and fast evidence it would be
it would seem that there isn't a need
for these
properties at the moment in that village
so you know i don't know if anyone else
has got got any other views on the
matter but
it does seem to be stacking up against
it
thank you any other views or that
no one's coming forward then from the
chair i will have to
make a proposal i'm going to move the
officer's recommendation that's before
us on the papers do i have a second hand
may i just quickly i it was said oh am i
switched on all right
yeah um it was said earlier the app
quite rightly the applicant isn't here i
had an email from the case officer this
morning and
mr carmichael can i just check that was
a short statement from the applicant did
that go to members as a late paper
that's that hasn't gone to members there
is a point i was just uh because i'm
just
um thinking about it because i've just
seen this as well um
is that arguably if the app as we're in
it's part of public speaking
we wouldn't usually have a statement
from the applicant in table papers that
would arguably
lobbying whereby we wouldn't have a
statement
put forward to members that we couldn't
um
have accountability for so many couldn't
question that point
back of the accuracy of any statement i
believe we have
had that in the past as well haven't we
missed a prayer so that's why it hasn't
been included and
arguably it could have been sent to all
members um and did not need to come
through table play first
you mr mr chairman thank you mr
carmichael i just wanted to make sure i
understood the status of what we'd
received this morning and that's
been explained and that is quite right
and proper thank you
the point is simply the applicant isn't
here
they they could have sent it directly to
all members of the committee as
as lobbying which would have been
declared but they they've not and it was
it was
it was not sent early enough to the case
officer for her to deal with it
in a detailed and appropriate way so um
that that's
i'm quite content now having asked that
question
thank you uh right do i have a second
um councillor osborne
yeah thank you mr chairman um yes i'd
i'd uh
be glad to uh second the proposal
for refusal the officer's recommendation
i think
uh and looking through the the
presentation that
has been before us i can't see
anything that uh has actually altered
any and
influenced any change of the refusal so
i'm happy to second that
thank you very much for that uh any
other comments from members
uh councillor busby well there's just a
feeling with this that we're
we're gradually picking off bits of that
field and it's actually going to expand
further and further into the countryside
i think there's got to be a point where
we say
enough's enough and i think we've we've
got 15 houses
which is plenty i think for that
particular site
it would also affect the the caravan
and mobile home area which has got
planning permission
which would be kind of a change of use i
guess so i think
i'm not i'm not in favor of a potential
big development being broken down into
small chunks which stop us getting any
affordable housing contributions
so i'm not in favor of this
thank you uh councillor mclaren
thank you chair uh i just found the
um mention of arms house is rather
misleading
to the discussion considering what we
think
arms houses are about so i i found that
difficult to accept
thank you thank you for that yeah we did
have it explained
but you're quite right thank you
no other comments no right then i will
ask the governance officer to
take us through the um
electronic vote
thank you chair that's it that's your
read today
thank you chair so if members could
please go to the modern.gov app and go
to
the plus sign in the top right hand
corner and that will show
that the subsection of voting and
attendance
the vote is now shown in progress once
you click on that in a light blue color
sorry that was very quick that last bit
i didn't hear it
i was going to say chair it's the same
as it always is but i can run through
again
no value point taken
right go on to the blue bit press that
the officer's recommendation for refusal
that's right
yeah before
thank you chair all votes have now been
received and that's
carried unanimously thank you thank you
very much we'll now move
on to page
91 and again it's
samantha we're still in action
okay thank you
thank you um this application seeks
outline planning permission
for the erection of four dwellings at
assington barns
the application comes to committee as
the applicant is the same as the
previous
application pre-application was entered
into
and a negative response given
this is the application site marked in
the hatched pink area
which sits to the north of the barn
buildings
it currently forms a polytunnel an
informal car parking area
as well as the access point to the
caravan park
the red line shows the application site
with site access
from the car parking area for ashington
barns
the blue line shows the extent of the
land ownership by the applicant
which includes the previous site and
field beyond
the application site is wholly within a
landscape a special landscape
area there is a listed building to the
north of the site
this is not considered to be a
constraint to this application
because of the distance between the two
and also planning permission has been
granted
for housing between the application site
and the listed building
the site sits outside of the built-up
area boundary of ashington which is
shown with the
brown line
this shows the new settlement boundary
proposed in the emerging joint local
plan
the purple line is the settlement
boundary the site is shown by the blue
star
the site is within the new settlement
boundary
although the site is within the
settlement boundary this is not a site
that is allocated for new housing
in the assington draft neighborhood plan
the site for 15 dwellings at assington
barn
is shown in red the site is shown with
uh with a blue star and sits outside of
that
housing allocation
this plan shows the housing sites that
have been
given planning permission and also oh
sorry around the site to the east is the
15 dwellings that are currently under
construction
and to the north a further site for
eight dwellings
the application site is shown with the
blue star
the yellow land is zoned as community
facilities
and includes the public house allotments
farm shop and village hall
the site is the farm shop site
the farm shop is considered to be a
valued community facility and supports
several small businesses
if the proposed dwellings were to be
built it would impact on future
expansion
of this important facility
this plan taken from the draft
neighborhoods plan shows
the housing sites for essington and the
community facilities
the applications sites the application
site is shown with the
blue star
this is the indicative layout for the
four dwellings
mandy would you mind uh just getting
your
thing me up thank you
sorry yeah so in the top left hand
corner of that site
yeah there's four small dwellings that
are just shown
if you just move along to the right side
yeah so these are
they're the proposed four dwellings
the houses have been tugged away behind
the business units
additional parking for ashington barns
is also proposed to the front of the
dwellings
the layout looks very cramped and the
result is that the site is car dominated
and the houses have very small gardens
they are out of keeping with the other
dwellings that have been approved
which have good spacing between and much
larger gardens
the indicative drawings uh show
armhouse style dwellings a single story
with two bedrooms
it has been proposed that these would be
for the over 60s
there is a question of whether this is a
suitable site for older people in terms
of getting to the doctors and shops
assington barn includes a farm shop but
it is unclear
what variety of products are available
for day-to-day living
it was difficult to get photographs of
the site because it is quite contained
so this aerial photograph probably shows
the site in context better really
the proposed dwellings would be where
that pulley tunnel are and would run
north to south along the boundary hedge
um the access point for
for the dwellings would be through a
cart entrance
from the car parking area
this photograph shows that carte
entrance and the car parking area is the
tallest roofline that you can see there
and you just pass underneath that to get
uh
currently to the caravan site but this
would be for
the poor dwellings and for the extra car
parking
this is taken uh from the caravan park
side and the
proposed dwellings would be along the
tree line
where that big motor home is currently
stationed
the proposed dwellings are considered to
form a cramped development that is
essentially within a car park
the development would not reflect the
existing pattern of development
if the development went ahead it is
likely that it would impact future
growth of the barn complex
the application has failed to evidence
that development would not result in an
increased risk of off-site flooding
the proposal is contrary to policies
cs11 cs15
of the core strategy and policy assn
22 of the neighbourhood plan which deals
with community facilities
this application is recommended for
refusal as set out on page 107
of your agendas thank you thank you very
much for that report
right we'll move to public speakers
oh no sorry uh questions for members is
there any questions you've got
to the yes counselor asked
thank you chair um i was just sad to do
um here about the
very small gardens since we've had this
awful virus so many more people
need a larger garden don't they even if
they are over 60
so how big would the garden be
how big are these gardens have you a
rough idea um i don't have a rough idea
i'm afraid because it is actually an
indicative plan so i think it would be
misleading to give you
but from the plans that are shown on on
the indicative layout
they do appear to be very small the
argument could be
that they are for over 60s and people
may not want the larger gardens that
would be
suitable for family living
that's a good point as well any other
uh councillor busby said they came in
for pre-application advice
uh was there any
did we put forward any proposal which
would have got approval
so um we did talk about both sites
jointly on the pre-application
discussions
um i did make it very clear that it
would be dependent
on uh providing evidence of local need
because that was something that was
missing from the previous application
for 19 that was refused
however i also advised the applicant
that he should look closely at the
neighborhood plan
because we knew that it was moving along
and would progress
probably in the time that the
application was received
this is one of the reasons that the
application has taken quite a long time
to come to committee
because it was under examination and we
wanted to see what the examiner was
going to say
about the policies within the
neighbourhood plan
but because that has now got such
strength
and uh quite a lot of weight
uh that is the document that we're
basing quite a lot of
um our decisions on today
so in a nutshell you made him
made the applicant aware of all the
other
situations that could develop um as i
say
um at pre-application stage we did
discuss what would be needed
for an application and that hasn't
actually come in
thank you i think that helps cancer
busby any other
uh counselor mclaren thank you sure
um where is the nearest
doctor's surgery to this site
um the parish probably can tell you
about i would assume if the school
is in boxford then probably the nearest
doctor's surgery would be
boxford but i'm not too sure
mr hill can you just answer that point
please i think it would actually be
viewers which is about four miles away
okay and i'll ask i'll
actually ask the parish council for the
next question
thank you chair thank you uh we got the
answer anyway on that part
uh any other questions
no um
fine okay we'll carry on um
thank you we'll now go to public
speakers
and mr hill parish council
over to you you sir have three minutes
in which address the committee
i suspect i probably won't take three
minutes because i haven't got a huge
amount to add
this this application clearly should
have been submitted at the same time in
the same application as the previous one
is clearly on the same site and
therefore all the issues about flooding
about the inappropriateness of the the
style of the buildings
and the lack of a housing needs
assessment all equally applying to this
this application as well um the only
thing i would add really is is that
one of the frustrations i'm sure you're
aware that people are frustrated about
planning in the district
i don't need to tell you that and one of
the frustrations is that these
applications come through in piecemeals
so in ascertain we've had applications
for 10 houses and we have an application
next door for six houses
no social housing whatsoever here we've
had an application for seven
for eight for three and now for four
and another um 18
and again no social housing whatsoever
so when the parish council looked at
this one and saw
four small bounce houses
we thought great we're actually going to
get a site with some
social housing on it um but of course
you look at the application format and
this is not social housing this is
this is a housing for market sale uh as
the officer said
the gardens are absolutely tiny and
we're talking less than 10 square meters
in
i would estimate um looking at the plans
and these days i don't understand this
thing that the over 60s don't want a
garden i'm afraid
uh there's lots of over 60s who spend
most of their time in the garden in our
village certainly and
my parents certainly are you know in the
vegetable patch for most of their life
so i don't understand the argument at
all
um people want outdoor space um so
and finally i just like to finish on the
neighborhood plan again
i said people have got lots of
disillusionment with the planning
process
and the fact that we have peacemaker
applications and what they perceive to
be inappropriate development
being approved all the time um people's
expectation is that
this will be the amount of effort they
put into it this will be taken seriously
and it will be
um effectively what is what future
applications are judged against
uh and clearly the the applicant hasn't
made any effort to comply with the
neighborhood plan
so again on behalf of the parish council
i'd ask you to agree with the
officer's recommendation for refusal
thank you
i think i'll just comment on that and
say that your comments
regarding the piecemeal is often echoed
by councillor busby
so we are reminded of that and are aware
but
in fairness any application that is put
forward by an applicant
has to be considered on its merits and
and does
come forward to us so we can't pick and
choose
so thank you and i'll see if there's any
questions for you
uh councilman mclaren thank you chair
um i'll continue where i left off last
time
um obviously in your village you've got
older people
how do they access say shops and
surgery is there a regular bus service
or
do they have to get taxis if they don't
drive
there used to be a regular bus service
which was reasonably frequent
we're now down to two services a day
basically so
um you have to get a doctor's
appointment at
one specific time and you can imagine
everyone wants that time so
it's extremely difficult so we're
talking taxis and
if you haven't got private transport
this application
would be just adding to the problem of
the village actually of accessing
services for older people unfortunately
yes but we are actively
engaged with the bus companies and and
that side of things try and improve but
but there's um been unsuccessful so far
yeah thank you very much thank you chair
thank you any other
uh counselor heirs thank you very much
councillor hill um is there a need
for someone is there a need for
social housing there if you know maybe
i'm not saying babies should buy some
land and build some social housing
but is there a need for it there
i think i think i can't say definitively
but
i think clearly there's a lot of young
people who need housing and
no doubt that includes ashington so um
within the nato plan we have
allocated the site which doesn't have
planning permission and which would be
looked very faithfully on
for social housing and there's actually
a separate policy in here which
promotes social housing specifically
i think that's nice to hear because you
must look at younger people
who want to stay in the villages thank
you councillor very much
thank you chair um i just wondered i'm
not sure whether it's a question for the
village or the officer really but you've
talked about
the um possibility that this
could constrain development or further
expansion at the
businesses the barns can you explain a
little bit more about
exactly what
that's unknown yeah no thank you very
much
then we'll move on we have an objector
helen wallace again
you might have had three minutes to
address the committee okay
hi thanks again uh really it won't be
very long but it's just to endorse all
that mr hill has
already said and maybe just to give a
local fl
feel about the village um we've already
mentioned the bus route so
unfortunately um it has been reduced and
there's also
thoughts of having the bus stop on the
main a134
and for villagers to walk to the 134 we
haven't got a continuous footpath
from this site right up to the 134 we
have some
dangerous corners which we're always
highlighting to
um highways and so it there are some
dangerous areas to
just be solely reliant on on the bus
route the other thing is the farm shop
we love our farm shop and we wouldn't be
without it it's been fantastic
over the covid lockdown period
but it isn't the cheapest shop in the
world we have a range of cheaper things
but just to be reliant on that
as your main grocery place you would
have to
have quite a substantial income
and the other thing is just we've really
tried very
hard to keep to our linear village and
not to try and create double rows of
housing
and so these these houses are starting
to
form that double row which we're trying
desperately
not to do um as with the previous settle
uh previous discussions we had that goes
so far back behind barracks road that
it's forming a double row
of houses in the village which is again
detracting from the
linear character that we have at the
moment
yeah and just as an over 60 i would not
want to be in a very small home without
a garden
surrounded by car parks so it's not
exactly
ideal positioning for these smaller
homes
i'd like to thank mr thane for actually
taking on board some of the neighborhood
plan
that we do need some smaller homes but
it's not just to be tucked in anywhere
and for over 60s we actually need them
for young
starter homes for young families as well
as i'm sure most villages do
thank you thank you
questions have any questions to the
objective
no thank you very much we'll move on
um we don't have a supporter
present or the applicant
so our name will now move into debate
as penceler parker has decided to stay
as a member of the planning committee
because he's also the ward member
in which case i will now ask him to open
the debate
thank you thank you chair and again i'll
um i'll i'll be brief because i think
that
between the officers report and um
the representations that we've heard
from the parish council i think that
actually all of the items are adequately
addressed
mr german one thing i would just
highlight again uh
is is the emergence of the neighbourhood
plan and as the officer mentioned
previously
it is the foremost document that we have
here and it's very clear
that this application is contrary um
uh to ashington neighbourhood's plan um
draft policy ass n22
so we we've made great store of
neighborhood plans and forthcoming
neighbourhood plans and
more and more of them are now starting
to um to
to emerge and i think we have
uh a moral obligation where those plans
hold significant weight to uphold
uh those plans as the principal document
so i i think
probably on balance that the uh the
recommendation within the
in the report is probably the correct
one mr chairman um so
that's all i'll say for that for now
thank you thank you yes
good plans are very important now and
particularly when they've gone all
through and they're accepted
um any other comments uh
cancellers
thank you chair um i do know the area
very well i've enjoyed the farm shop
and 18 ashington bonds but just
the fact that the doctor's surgery is
viewers that road between ashington
and viewers it's very very narrow
and i wouldn't like to have to travel it
particularly if i was feeling
not well at all so i think not having a
doctor's is is quite
a significant thing and i totally agree
with everything councillor parker said
and i would propose that we do not
accept this planning we go with the
officer's
um decision thank you advice go with the
officer's decision
yes sorry yeah on the papers yep
thank you would you just like to say
that to us
so that's not my words i would fully
support
the officer's advice on what we should
do
about this application and that it is
refused
thank you know that we go with
what the officer has suggested
i propose
uh do i have a second to cancel a plum
thank you chair yes i think we should do
everything we can to support
neighborhood plans
and i congratulate the village of
washington on getting the thrives it has
um and let's make sure that we all take
notice of it so i therefore second
motion to refuse
uh right there's no other comments then
oh yes there is the councillor
buzzfeed of course there is i just think
it's a shame we've missed an opportunity
or i think
the applicant's missed an opportunity
here i think there's a there's a it
seems to me that
there could be an opportunity here for
some employment
starter units or something along those
lines um
or expansion of the barnes area i think
by putting
coming forward with just houses that
blocks that off
and one of the things that the area i
think every village could do with is
some
employment opportunities and it may be
that you could put some flats above
those
four first-time buyers and therefore you
get a double benefit
whereas this to me is just it's just not
an attractive
proposition which is why i ask whether
whether we've given any other advice
which they could have come forward
with so yeah
no isn't that right
thank you um councillor barrett was the
question you wanted to put forward
to the officers um well i was going to
ask about
uh you talked about um
the options to to build on the
the the um nature of the barns be being
commercial
uh and whether whether that had been um
talked about but
i think we've probably gone past that
that stage now i think um
you know so i'll leave it for and
councillor busby's talked on it talked
about it as well so yeah yes i think has
supposedly made some good points on that
actually any other comments
no right it's been proposed and seconded
i'll ask
sorry councillor osborne
sorry thank you mr chairman
yes i i fully uh fully agree with what's
been said
today uh on this particular application
it's
to me that you have got the
policies in line with this one and again
i think uh the presentation that sam has
given has been excellent
i would say that um
having small gardens for older people
is not actually um a good thing
uh in terms of the as
as the assington uh clerk has said
uh they they spend a lot of time in the
garden and
the mental health side of it does a lot
of older people a lot of
a lot of a lot you know a lot better
than having to sit indoors and watch the
television
um to me and from the previous site
visits we've carried out and i think
there's been about
two or three you've already got
a caravan site there you've already got
people coming in and out during the year
if they are going to continue i cannot
see the point of having
uh houses there which is seems to me
a dripping tap it just it'll just keep
coming and coming
and coming until you eventually have as
councillor busby said
had to chop it off thank so um
i'm i'm not in favor of this and i i
absolutely agree with the reviews
of the officer thank you thank you
councillor osborne uh
no other comments haven't missed anybody
no good okay i'll now ask
um rob to read it out and take us to the
electronic vote
thank you rob thank you chair so
the recommendation is that application
dc2100510
be refused as detailed in the office of
recommendation
the vote has now started members so if
you could please go to the plus sign on
your on today's agenda
and go to the subsection on voting
attendance and on there it will show at
the bottom
the light blue color and you may need to
scroll down to get to that one
just waiting for one more vote chat
there we are that's all been received
said that is a unanimous vote for the
proposal for refusal
thank you thank you very much for that
well members we've got through this
morning's meeting
um we haven't done too bad i don't think
i'd have you made too many
mistakes so uh thank you all for your
patience
uh the last thing to remind the date and
time of the next meeting
is scheduled for wednesday the 16th of
june
2021 at 9 30 a.m
sorry just to bring on in on that point
next meeting will
be um it won't be
then the next one is on the
oh jesus friday the 4th
of uh june all right
let's just show us how my paperwork can
go out of date so quickly
um yes so the date of the next meeting
is friday the 5th of june
at 9 30 here at endeavour house
okay can i ask why it's not a wednesday
um
because it's a friday unless you could
uh
tell me anything different um you cannot
understand the same as everybody else
how difficult it is to operate a diary
without
any structure to it one thing we could
always bank on was that planning was on
a wednesday
fridays are usually kept free i have
books i have rearranged a dentist
appointment for a friday i'm gonna have
to rearrange it again
you can't fill every day with potential
haphazard
meetings we've got to have some spare
space that we can work with yeah
well i'm very sorry it's caused an
inconvenience and a problem to you
it has to me also but these were the
dates that was the date i was given
there wasn't a lot of choice and so
friday the fourth foot is
uh cancer parker
well i've taken kenzler parker next
pencil parker sorry yeah can i can i
just so what do we know when that when
the next
planning meeting after the fourth of
june is it's not like the following week
or anything is it
right well i'll say you know if robert
can help us that
thank you chair so if i address both
points if that would be helpful
would you like me to address both points
if that would be helpful so the
reason why we have the meeting on the
fourth is because of the annual council
meeting next week so basically
from the point of that we the committee
is reconstituted so we can't have the
committee
for five clear working days following
that so that's why and that's
following the first day of that because
we've got a mid suffix meeting on the
thursday next week
and one on the friday because of the
five clear working days and because
as mr russell know 10 can't
that's the correct word thank you um
that we have a large number of planning
applications and we still need to keep
feeding them through the system so i
i realize and understand that that does
cause problems for members
but we still have to keep going and the
schedule will continue
and go back into its normal form of
wednesdays following that and i do
believe that
it should go back to that point it's
just because of the annual meeting and
the five clear working days that we have
to meet to do that
and the next one to confirm will be
following that will be the 16th so we
then go back to normal schedule
following that
so that is the fourth and the next one
would be the 16th
yeah well after what we've been through
this last year i should think a little
[Music]
alternate of dates is a small price to
pay
so anyway we're now at the end of the
meeting and i intend to declare the
meeting closed thank you very much
you